après avoir tapé 45 minutes associés
elle se retourne vers moi et elle me dit
par le bras pour des jeunes qui veulent
réussir en tennis j'ai quelques conseils
d'abord le premier conseil c'est prendre
soin ça paraît évident mais c'est la
plus grande difficulté parce que quand
on joue au tennis professionnellement il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de défaites
il ya beaucoup de moments difficiles et
c'est le moment où on perd la croyance
en soi et lorsqu'on perd la trace en
soit on n'y arrive pas donc il faut
avoir fait son meilleur supporters il
faut croire en soi à tout instant et
quoi qu'il arrive du début à la fin de
sa carrière
ensuite il faut avoir retour de soi des
gens qui non seulement sont compétents
mais qui sont aussi nos supporters il
faut toujours s'entourer de gens qui
croient en nos capacités
sa part est aussi une évidence mais ce
n'est pas toujours le cas et c'est ça
une valeur inestimable
ces gens là ils vont nous porter
troisième chose bien connaître son
identité de jeu c'est commencer de jeu
et il faut toujours jouer son style de
jeu ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu
aux entraînements c'est très important
de travailler ses points forts plus que
c'est point faible je dis pas qu'il faut
pas travailler ses points faibles et il
faut se concentrer sur ce qu'on fait de
mieux
parce que c'est avec ce qu'on fait mieux
qu'on va devenir le plus fort dans tous
les jours travaillés sont fait mieux et
quand on est en match toujours
réutiliser ses qualités et respecter son
identité de jeu si je suis un attaquant
je dois jouer un jeu d'attaqué
quoi qu'il arrive même quand j'ai peur
même quand on adversaire remet beaucoup
de balles
même quand je pense qu'il va me donner
le match parce qu'il a beaucoup il faut
continuer à attaquer parce que à chaque
jour lorsqu on compétitionne jours
lorsqu'on compétition on joue son jeu
progrès sont sensibles de jeu et on
devient meilleur amour un double academy
notre mission est d'aider les jeunes à
exploiter 100 % de leur potentiel tout
le monde a un potentiel et notre
objectif c'est qu'ils aillent au bout
d'eux mêmes et qu'il n'ait plus aucun
regret le jour où ils arrêteront leur
carrière alors ça c'est vrai évidemment
dans le tennis mais c'est vrai aussi
dans les études et on croit énormément
avouera tout bleu académie depuis le
premier jour que les deux sont aussi
importants
en
je suis devenu le coach de serena parce
que j'étais un coach sur le circuit
j'avais travaillé avec beaucoup de
joueurs professionnels
mes joueurs avaient eu pas mal de succès
avec moi on est c'est un petit monde de
tennis temple tout le monde chacun
s'observe et les joueurs ont des
préférences
il ya des gens avec qu'ils ont un bon
contact où ils ont envie avec lesquels
ils ont envie de travailler
évidemment ils regardent aussi les
résultats qu'obtiennent les différents
coachs et en 2012
serena jay à une période de sa carrière
qui est un petit peu difficile
elle n'a pas gagné de grand chelem
depuis deux ans elle est un peu descendu
au classement et elle vient de perdre au
premier tour de roland garros
elle est à paris elle sait que mon
académie mouratoglou academy donc on
était limité lice est à paris et elle me
téléphone et me demande si elle peut
venir se préparer pour wimbledon à
l'académie elle arrive elle s'entraîne
avec deux sparring partner ce qu'elle
m'a demandé je la laisse s'entraîner je
suis juste là pour veiller à ce que tout
se passe bien et puis après avoir tapé
45 minutes elle s'assied elle se
retourne vers moi et elle me dit
parlement grosso modo elle veut que je
lui donne un feedback par rapport à ce
qu'elle fait sur le terrain elle veut
savoir ce que je pense de son jeu et
puis éventuellement tu donnes des
conseils donc je sais que j'ai quelques
secondes pour lui donner mon avis est
que ces quelques secondes sont
importantes dans ma carrière je lui
explique que ce que je vois sur le coup
à l'entraînement c'est exactement la
même chose que ce que j'ai vu dans son
match qu'elle a perdu face à wihr
général
le retour de roland garros les mêmes
erreurs et elle me répond très bien
est-ce qu'on peut travailler là dessus
je dis bien sûr on travaille sur
notamment son équilibre sur son
transfert vers l'avant et puis ça marche
très bien
elle commence à sentir de mieux en mieux
se sentir de mieux en mieux sur le court
elle me demande si on peut retravailler
sa lé les jours suivants et puis
finalement on travaille pendant une
semaine au quotidien et wimbledon qui
est le tournoi suivant lors de wimbledon
elle me demande si je peux m'occuper
d'elle pendant le tournoi
à l'époque je m'entraîne grigor dimitrov
et gregor accepte que je vais m'occuper
d'eux pendant ce wimbledon et il se
trouve que serena va gagner wimbledon en
simple et en double et évidemment c'est
difficile d'arrêter après après avoir
regagné 1,3 de grand chelem
donc on décide de continuer à travailler
ensemble et les résultats s'enchaînent
je dirais pas que serena et serena parce
qu'elle a un physique puissant je dirais
même l' inverse
parce que au tennis le gabarit idéal et
on le voit trop niveau c'est des joueurs
qui sont plutôt filiforme comme novak
djokovic vous rodger federer a tout
simplement parce que c'est un sport de
changement de direction et que
évidemment plus on des légers plus on a
la possibilité de changer de direction
rapidement et à moins de contraintes sur
le corps en revanche serena a mis l'eau
de qualité
alors évidemment c'est une
extraordinaire athlètes ça c'est une
qualité
mais sa plus grande force c'est son
mental c'est une joueuse qui est
exceptionnel sur le plan mental c'est
une extraordinaire compétitrices c'est
une gagneuse
et c'est ça qui fait sa spécificité et
puis enfin pour être la plus grande
championne championne de tous les temps
le mental c'est évidemment essentiel et
primordial mais il faut d'autres
qualités et dieu sait qu'elle en a un
sens du jeu
très bon sens du jeu tellement de
faiblesse et les fortes des deux côtés
et puis elle a probablement le plus
grand service de l'histoire du tennis
ça fait quand même beaucoup de qualités
qui explique qu'elle est la plus grande
joueuse de tous les temps